what's going on everybody welcome to
part 24 of the intermediate Python
series in this tutorial what we're going
to be talking about are the string and
wrapper methods or the dunder string
dunder wrapper methods so these two
methods are very similar and a lot of
times people ask like what's the main
difference in reality you really can get
by just with a wrapper method but in
general the dunder string method is
meant to be like a human readable
description of your object and then the
wrapper method is really it's still
human readable ish as long as someone's
usually familiar at least slightly with
your object but also the wrapper methods
more meant for just kind of debugging
purposes not really to be something that
you would actually show somebody in
production or something like that but
they are interchangeable to a degree in
a lot I've seen people that just simply
have a reprimanded they don't even
bother with a string method so what
exactly do they do well first of all we
can show a quick example with a module
that exists and everybody has it and
we're gonna do the date/time module so
you can either follow along or just you
follow along the code or just kind of
watch this part won't really be
necessary that you code with me so I'm
just gonna run this real quick just so
we can get into a shell I'm gonna import
date/time and then if I do something
like this date time dot date/time dot
now and I'm gonna go ahead and copy this
so I'm gonna keep writing that a
thousand times if I just hit enter here
what we get is the wrapper method
because we're just referencing the
object we haven't asked this object to
say be printed which would give us the
string representation so just printing
it or just just stating the object in
the shell like this returns the repre
method as opposed to just printing it
will by default give us the string
method if there is no string method it
will give us the wrapper method so if
there is if there was no string method
we would actually just see this but the
other way you can you can be certain of
this as you could just do wrapper quite
literally paste and there you have that
and also you can do string
and there you have that now what about
with our our blob Jets right what and I
guess also like why would you want to
have string and repre methods like
what's the whole point
well at least by default the string of
reprimanded or at least what you'll have
right now which is repper is worthless
so what I'm gonna go ahead and do is
copy these lines and now you do want to
be following along if you don't have
this code like if you're just hopping
into this tutorial go to Python
programming at net go to the Python
fundamentals part 24 and copy and paste
the code it'll be a kind of near the top
of the script so now what we're gonna do
is since we got the code here let's go
ahead and run this
pretty sure I hit and-run there we go
we're just hanging for a second and now
let's print blue blobs and we'll just
reference the zeroeth blue blob what we
get is is absolutely useless all right
and again which is this is clearly a
reprimand but your chances are you might
not be alive anyway we'll just do it
again just to see okay so yeah we're
definitely dealing with just a wrapper
and as you can see this this default
repre method is useless so what we might
want to do is actually make our own and
we saw at least one example of why you
would want to do this in the previous
tutorial like when we were logging for
debugging purposes it can be really
useful if your methods actually are if
your objects actually have string and
wrapper methods we didn't at the time
but now we're going to add some so let's
close this and now what I'm going to go
ahead and do is head on over to the
actual blob hi so this is the that what
we're actually importing this is our
blob class the base class anyways
they're the parent class we are
modifying that up here with the blue
blobs and the red blobs and the green
blobs but we don't have to give each of
these their own reprimanded we actually
just need we could just do it in this
parent class here so what I'll do is
just come down here and now I'm going to
go ahead and do a dunder
repper and we just need to pass self we
do need the other donors though and now
we're gonna do is just obviously it just
returns a string right and like we were
saying the reprimands really more kind
of for debugging purposes it should be
as condensed as possible we're not
really it's not really meant to be
output to a console in production use
it's just really for debugging so what
we're going to do is we're gonna return
and will return the lob and then the
information we're going to give on this
blob basically it's going to be size
color and then we'll do x and y okay so
then we're gonna do dot format and then
self dot it in fact actually we'll do
color first because the color is more
important so we'll do self dot color and
then self dot size self dot x and self
dot Y so now we have reprimanded let's
save that
let's pop on over to blob world looks
good and now let's print blue blobs zero
and now at least we have something a
little more useful we've got the color
again this is an RGB the size and then
the XY coordinates location so someone
who's actually familiar with these blob
objects should be able to when they see
this in any sort of debugging
immediately no okay this has to be the
color I'm not certain what six is but
since we know these blob objects have
color a size and a location I can just
deduce that size and then from here
these two things in parentheses it's not
totally clear what they are but it's
probably XY right and we could also go
to the actual reprimanded just to see
what it actually is printing out but
that's you want to keep it as just
simple as as that and just basically
it's just for debugging purposes and as
you can see because we did print that
should have been a string method but
since we don't have one it's just going
to fall back to the
method but if we said if we just now
reference the object we're not trying to
reference the string method it's still
obviously the repre method now let's go
ahead and add a string method so they
pulled it back up whoops there we go I'm
just gonna copy this cuz it's gonna be
very very similar just gonna have
slightly more information and just be
easier to read so change it to string
now blob you might say you you could
either have like blob and print the seas
or you might get rid of even the
parentheses here and you could say like
blob of color something like that and
then comma size and then location and
we'll tab these over just to be as close
it's probably not gonna be perfect
oh my goodness it worked it's oh that
feels really good when that stuff
happens
all right it's gonna be a good day
so now let's save and run that mmm I
hope I saved it I think I did let me
check before I waste time yep okay so
print now blue blobs zero and again this
should be great yes so we got the string
version and again now if we do blue
blobs 0 we get the rep reversion as
opposed to obviously print gives us the
string version so it just has a little
bit more information a little easier to
read but yeah it's almost like twice as
long but now what we could do is we
close this like when we go to our actual
blob world pie and we do things like
logging let me find the first log let's
see tried raised that exception logging
in so like here blob add operation and
then we were doing the like string
formatting and we were just doing self
dot color well instead what we could say
now is the string version of self and
the string version of other blob right
we didn't we don't have to reference any
of the attributes because now we
actually have something that
we could also we could say repper rather
than scream just to make our logging
file even smaller but I'll leave it
there and then again here checking if
two blobs are touching this was that
debugging it's like you could change
that now because again we were just
using the color but instead we could
just do the actual blobs and then I
think we had another one down here but
yeah I guess we're not doing it so we
could clear this that we can save this
and let's see what was our logging
we're on info right now and let me do an
info just to so when to add operations
happen we should see a new form of
adding I haven't seen any happen just
yet we will see one here yep okay so
hopefully we've got a new log there
let's open the log file and go down at
the very very very bottom and sure
enough we have slightly better
information here now on our actual blobs
all of us obviously have a little bit
more information we might actually want
to log the repper rather than the string
version of the objects but yeah anyway
just supposed to be an example of string
and remember I think I'll change these
and I must be zooming by it oh here we
go
wrapper and then this repartee r okay
all is well in the world let's run that
one just to see somebody's touch these
Blues are touching I'm pretty sure
that'll still throw a log even though
that doesn't matter if they touch each
other that blues blue blobs at the
moment but I'm waiting for these to
touch each other so one of these guys
got it there we go whoo that's a big
blue blob he's gonna be taken over soon
okay now check the log file again scroll
on down to the very very bottom it's a
little more concise now whoops there we
go oh my goodness there we go yeah cool
so anyway that's the string and repair
method it's just a couple more special
methods that I are really useful
actually to know about especially if
you're writing your own your own classes
and all that so if you have any
questions comments concerns something
else you want to bring up let us know
below otherwise I will see you in
another tutorial